imagine you were given some tasks to
carry out at work over three years ago
not only did you fail but you managed to
make matters spectacularly worse or
you'd agreed to a fairly major building
project at your home and all this time
on not one brick had been laid in fact
you hadn't even been able to agree to
the down plans it's safe to assume you
could expect the sack divorce or a
dwindling bank account not so if you
were part of team and may the biggest
bunch of laugh out losers since
England's opening batsmen because the
gang that couldn't shoot straight and
from day one conducted brexit
negotiations on bended knee and with cap
in hand were rewarded with a battery of
gongs
in two resumes farewell on his list
chief brexit bungler holly Robins got a
knighthood and former Chiefs of Staff
Fiona Hill and Nick Timothy who presided
over the 2017 election that destroyed
two resumes Authority got CBE's Mrs May
said she quotes riched violently when
David Cameron did a similar thing a
couple of years ago this week I knew how
she felt Theresa May is really going to
live to regret that wretch violently I
think it's a relief to see that we can
actually agree about something although
I have to say I find it interesting how
Nick Timothy and Fiona hilt resumes to
advisers were kind of the bogeyman this
time last year they were the ones being
blamed for everything that was going
wrong I have to say now looking at Boris
Johnson and Dominic Cummings they don't
seem so bad in comparison but I agree I
think that the way that the honor system
rewards political advisers is incredibly
difficult to square with the idea of a
modern democracy it just thinks of
corruption and nepotism but I would add
to your list of grievances the cricketer
Geoffrey Boycott
because awarding an honour which is
meant to represent a person's valour
that's traditionally what it is supposed
to symbolize to somebody who has a
conviction for domestic violence for
assaulting a former girlfriend is
completely at odds with with the values
I thought that we and Teresa may who's
behind this honor adopted as a nation
and I think it's just another example of
how out of touch that system of reward
is with the values we have as people
let's see if this new spirit
the cord stretches too young for me what
do you say is there a future for the
honor system well first I want to say I
back here 100% I think it's ridiculous
that you have one of the most unpopular
people in the country deciding who
should be put on a pedestal it is insane
and for Jeremy Geoffrey Parker boycott
after what he did after his attitude to
it that we've heard since it's
horrendous can I can I just because
we've been talking about Geoffrey
Boycott make sure everyone understands
the allegation but also what he says
about it so the reason that people have
an issue with Geoffrey Boycott me
awarded honors because he does have this
conviction in France for having
assaulted and ex-girlfriends and Edina
Claire who's the co acting chief
executive of women's aid says
celebrating a man who is convicted who
was convicted for assaulting his partner
sends a dangerous message that domestic
abuse is not taken seriously as a crime
it is extremely disappointing that a
knighthood has been recommended for
Geoffrey Boycott he was a convicted
perpetrator of domestic abuse but
Geoffrey Boycott
it is important to say denies even
though he was convicted in a French
court of law he denies that conviction
and this is what he says I have to live
with it and I do because I'm clear in my
mind and I think most people in England
that it's not true
although the chief executive of Women's
Aid has said celebrating a man I don't
get a toss about 25 years ago so you can
take your political nature and do
whatever you want with it you want to
talk to me about my knighthood is very
nice of you to have me but I couldn't
give a toss is that really the behaviour
of a knight of the realm
let's get Andrew in let's come back to
the political aspect of this I mean a
part because more yeah apart from the
fact she it was the honors this was a
reward for failure because Mrs May will
go down in history in my view is
probably the worst Prime Minister since
David Cameron and Boris Johnson goes out
shortly he'll be the worst prognosis
injuries that may but if I go into the
house at all tonight in quite often I'm
struck by how many ghosts from the past
are still hovering around in their 80s
going there to keep warm because it's
safe putting the central heating on at
home getting their 300 pounds tax-free
it's a gravy train and mrs. may should
have learned from David Cameron's on
resignation on assist which badly
tainted his last days in office and I
think this is tainted hurts well before
I give my view on the honor system let
me ask everyone question and answer
honestly
if you was honored or invited to be
honored would you accept it no generally
shouldn't take corners in my view would
you services to remain would you accept
it I mean I've never run into a burning
building so probably not would you it
says something I grapple with every day
because I'm in such realistic like it's
going to be it no I wouldn't I wouldn't
accept I certainly wouldn't accept an
OBE or anything referencing the Empire
and I can't see myself so it's so like
this how would you know I've thought
about this for journalism no I do do
quite a lot for charity different yes
for journalism I don't think it seals it
seems right let me be clear so just in
case if anyone wants to nominate me down
right I would accept someone but thank
you very much okay and I would take all
the packs that go were there and I find
all of this so hypocritical it's
unbelievable because actually I think
that awarding people for failure is an
absolute jerk it's in what suit you
across you know what I'm saying is some
of these people are getting these
honours they shouldn't be anywhere near
it because they all they're doing in the
first place is their job I'm they're
doing it flat yeah they're doing it
badly half the time so they shouldn't be
in there but then what then happens is
when people are pontificating about who
should get one and who shouldn't you get
this whole criticism of the whole system
and everyone sits and goes this is a
such a terrible system as we're all
doing around this table but then when it
goes their way and actually they're
awarded with one they're in that they're
in that House of Lords or there wherever
there are quicker than their feet will
take them and I found that that if
anyone's probably will be a four who get
one it wasn't because she's she's
written her books and she's done her
what she's not failed it's what half was
that she and my point at the very start
is and I appreciate you think
differently about Nick to many of you
know most of these people have at the
best done pretty poorly or failed I
Patrick McLoughlin Pat McLaughlin has
been awarded he now goes up I think only
650 people in the whole country have
rewarded he thought he was the one who
preside
over the set when it all fell apart
behind mrs. maylie he gets another
reward he's already a sir it's the way
in which it's conducted I think it's
good to reward people who do good things
not who fail first of all even if we
accept the system of honours and rewards
and peerages it's the way in which
they're appointed and it's completely
lacks transparency and I just don't know
can I take go back to my first type of
job as a journalist it was on the
Gloucestershire echo in Cheltenham the
honest list was a source of great joy
because lollipop lady thought when we're
getting em bees Oh bees people working
charge it brought great joy they were
going to go to the palace they might
meet the Queen they might meet Prince
Charles lovely photographs in it that's
what the honor system should be about
saluting our unsung heroes but MPs
should not be automatically entitled to
the night of when they've been an MP for
25 years they've had enough
I think there's an important element
about what it in our society who we put
on a pedestal for example we've got
Geoffrey Boycott after what he was
convicted of domestic abuse who somehow
managed to make his on be on his list
we've got Chris Brown to broaden out a
little bit further after what he did to
Rihanna beating her - we've all seen the
pictures yet he's still famous and still
seen as an idol by many that is
completely unacceptable
so are we saying just to broaden out
from a boycott that if you've got a
criminal conviction because don't forget
convictions get spent after a period of
time depending on what they're for but
are we suggesting that if you've had a
criminal conviction you cannot be on
people who've been convicted of tax
fraud who have been completely ruled out
of ever receiving an honour because of
that now I agree with that but I don't
see why it's it's okay if you've
committed a domestic violence I'm not if
you've committed attacks can I take you
back into the House of Lords you will
find on some of the bet you'll find all
the benches you will find a convicted
arsonist
you'll find a peer who drove his car
into something and killed him while he
was on texting on his phone you'll find
three or four peers who cheated on that
perhaps of all its expenses or went to
prison they're now all back in the house
rules legislating and claiming their tax
money how does that work how can that be
right order